welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast i'm your host hisham aziz and on
this week's episode i was joined by
jamie walker from paritus people jamie's
worked in recruitment for just under
three years in this episode we broke
down and dissected how jamie has gone
about achieving his weekly gp of over 20
grand a week we really dug into
how he approaches his day his day plan
break into big accounts work in
international markets and so much more
enjoy this episode
jamie welcome to the podcast i
appreciate it shame it's good to be here
yeah thanks for uh making the trip
obviously we've had a few people now
before there's a lot of people that are
in and around london so you come from
bristol right yeah person before you tom
from wales had people last time from
manchester so it's exciting i'm excited
to get more people in in the studio so
thanks for making the trip um
obviously today one i'm really excited
to sit down with you jamie why i was
excited to get connected with you was
obviously a lot of people who listen to
this show are
on the journey um
maybe one day they might think about
having their own business or maybe that
isn't something they want but i think a
lot of people that listen to this are
like in the thick of it which is like
where you're at today you're obviously
getting to the point of three years into
your recruitment journey
so i'm really excited to sort of unpack
the challenges what you've learned and
why you think you've been able to
really start building traction in your
contract recruitment career and then
we'll break all that down so
what i wanted to to start with and it'd
be great to get your thoughts on this
is just the million pound question
basically and that's
what what do you believe are the common
characteristics and traits that make up
a
high-performing recruitment consultant
in today's market do you think
it's it's a good topic right
i think everybody will have their own
view and opinion on this but for me
i think the biggest
focus is probably having a bit of hunger
and tenacity about how you go about
your day-to-day activities
if you break it down into like the
simplest forms of what you need to do
the job isn't actually that difficult
people make it difficult for themselves
and i think
having the hunger to attack
the difficult tasks
is important um
i think
going out there with a structured day
is important
and doing everything with a bit of
conviction
right you know and passion
you've got to enjoy i mean for me i love
my market i really thoroughly enjoy my
market i think
sitting in the discussions i get to get
to be involved with um it gets me really
excited
and then a year 18 months down the line
i'm starting to see everything that i've
worked on with my clients
yeah it's like it's out there in the
market you know
i could go around my parents house and
they sit there and they're they're
flicking through a sky tv
and i'm like i was part of that
you know i've so just put it in context
your market is we were just talking
about when we like video technology
for the home but you you explain it like
how you would describe like when you're
down with your mates and they're going
what the [ __ ] do you actually do like
how do you describe it because i think
that's that's the funniest thing right
is like my mates are just like what do
you actually do yeah and uh so i
describe it as like the digital tv
sector okay so
anything any device uh that you can
watch a streaming application on
um watch tv on um
that's essentially what we're involved
with so you know the old traditional
set-top boxes the sky boxes virgin boxes
you see in your home
um your smart tv applications your
netflix's yeah what sort of people then
would be involved in
businesses like that and that you focus
on do you then have a niche within the
type of people and skill set that you
yeah so i focus on sort of software
developers
anything in the software development
life cycle
my team focus on
six main development areas um and that's
usually
usually enables us to go from proof of
concept all the way through to taking
that
it's all centered around like you just
said the video technology in the home
and digital video sector
so that's really interesting so like you
said being willing to attack the day
have a plan do the basics well but then
what and i can tell you your life faces
up when you talk about it but what's
what's you i guess what hopefully
most people have in common if they're at
the top of their game is that they
actually are really curious about their
market they're really interested in it
they enjoy it they're passionate about
it as you said um so i guess just to
frame this up for people so obviously uh
this um middle of this year you'll have
your three milestone right
in recruitment
um
and that this has been your only
recruitment job isn't that yeah yeah so
where i wanted to start was like who was
jamie with full recruitment because
obviously from what i saw after you um
were in the royal navy right for a while
so talk to me about that who was jamie
how would you describe jamie before
recruitment because recruitment is often
an accident people don't look for it
there's always some interesting stuff
there so let's start there
recruitment was definitely an accident
right
but i think me before recruitment i was
probably actually a little bit lost
i joined the forces at quite a young age
right
i was
17 18 when i joined so i was i was i was
a young lad
i have family in in the forces that have
served or nobody at all where's that
where'd that come from so i grew up in
cheltenham uh
love football right typical football
story i've always thought i was just
going to play football yeah um didn't
work out
and wasn't very academic either at all
i was like thinking
what can i do to carry on playing
football
didn't really
have an interest in education or go into
sixth form college anything like that so
i looked at joining joining the forces
which is what i did
had a great time in there some great
mates very hard training but i got to
play football right
in what sense uh
if they if if the forces look at you and
and you know you're you're good at a
sport or you want to progress with
something they will literally let you
crack on with with that you know people
when they just play football whilst
doing that yeah whilst learning my trade
doing my basic training right
so
you know i spent a lot of time down down
in portsmouth whilst i was learning my
trade at the time which is warfare
and then in the evenings i'm being
shipped around everywhere to play
football against
other sites against the army against the
raf
and just i'm just having fun with your
mates right yeah um
it was quite it was quite a big step for
me but i think
i think for me you know i was as i said
i was like i felt a little bit lost in
my sort of videos for a good number of
years right yeah was it what i saw on
linkedin like four five years uh yeah
yeah yeah so it was it was it was a big
part of my life right
um
for me though there was always something
missing
i always thought that i wasn't being
challenged in a way that i wanted to be
a challenge i feel like you were
fulfilling your potential maybe yeah
yeah so
for me i sort of
it was quite uh it's quite a tough
period of my life right
i sort of you know
realized that something that i had aimed
to do for the rest of my life wasn't
what i wanted to do
didn't really have an education to
to fall back on or explore anywhere else
yeah i think i was 20
21 22
by the time i came out um
so
when i came out i was i felt a lot of
pressure back onto the call of sivi
street right
back at my mums yeah going
what do i do next
right
yes
in cheltenham like great great town like
i ended up you know a friend of mine was
working at a cocktail bar
i ended up just
doing some shifts there just to like
pass some time try and work out what i
wanted to do
ended up
somehow
running
uh an entire cocktail bar a team of
seven people seven eight people
um
and i did that for about a year yeah
then realized that you know right i'm
getting sucked into something that yes
it's fun it was enjoyable but again not
really what i wanted to do
i then got involved in car sales right i
was like i enjoy meeting people i enjoy
chatting and your idea had the people
element in the hospitality yeah like it
was great you know getting to know my
customers etc so i was like how can i
transition that into a into a job
car sales wicked
i did that for a couple of years and i
did really well you know i worked with
some really good brands um i moved to
bristol for for a job yeah um because of
it um so i think i've been in bristol
now for
four four years
wicked city it's like a home away from
home for me i think i was always going
to use it as a stepping stone to come to
london but
like my heart set set in bristol now
and yeah so
again sort of got
got
very good at selling cars but i was
working seven days a week yeah getting
in it was it was it sales that you found
because i i that's what i found like i
didn't know what i wanted to do i i was
delivering pizzas for dominoes i was
doing all different things i
might i ended up then deciding you know
what what would be a good idea is doing
two seasons and magaluf did that
and like but that that ended up being
the biggest catalyst because before i
went there i had no idea what i wanted
to do and then i just got myself
complete outside my comfort zone went
there on my own and the only job that i
could get was sales
and it was commission only do you know
what i mean so then i was in this
environment where i wouldn't be able to
pay my bills unless i sold things so but
then i actually really enjoyed it
because i i was i would say i was a
quite confident person i could speak to
people but i didn't know there was a
career in like utilizing those skills
you know what i'm in which sounds like
you sort of went on a bit of a journey
and then you found yourself an
environment where you were the biggest
thing for me that sales gave i don't
know if you found it and then why i'm so
excited about recruitment was like
you're rewarded by the effort you put in
that's that's i think that's exactly
what brought me to recruitment so for me
it was like i wasn't seeing a way in
uh in the dealership to to progress my
career yeah right unless i waited for
somebody to leave yeah
that that was the only way that i was
going to ever progress so for me
the turning point was actually sold a
car to somebody who owned a recruitment
company really yeah that's it so this is
what was it
yeah it was a volvo xc40 i was working
for volvo at the time great brand
absolutely loved it
um
and yeah we got chatting and he was like
have you ever thought about a career in
recruitment i was like it's never even
crossed my mind at all
um
and that sort of
sparked the the interest
yeah i started looking into it a little
bit
looking at different companies out there
and of course you can get lost right
doing that because there are so many
different recruitment companies
i think that that's what i think that's
what i love about this industry right
like you if you just listen to yourself
then like you went from a point of like
not sure what to do probably putting a
lot of pressure on yourself difficult
period you then just
lent into things that maybe you were
good at people
hospitality then car sales and then now
obviously recruiting for the last three
years and there's no reason why and the
great thing about the industry is that
industry wouldn't go well you haven't
got this so we're not going to look at
you do you know what i mean that's it so
let's break down the this la this sort
of last nearly three years and so just
to give context with people so you've
always
been in a contract recruitment
environment all right yep
so let's think about the first year
because i know
the last year where there's been some
real growth so i think what would be
really good for people
for for you to share like the challenges
how that first year was and then now in
hindsight the things that maybe you
showed up and did each day that you
think had a real impact on like why then
things started to build traction how
would you describe your first gen
recruitment
absolute baptism of fire
like it was mental um i probably at the
12-month mark or a little bit before
that did consider walking away really
yeah so why didn't you
so so for me right obviously i took a
massive i took a massive gamble with
coming into recruitment i took a big pay
cut i came onto a bait onto a low base
salary which practically just covered my
my bills
um
for me it was like it was a sink or swim
moment so
i came in uh to a new market
new company new new environment for me
this was the way the challenge that that
excited me right this is probably where
what i was looking for
i was given a market an area to focus on
which was testers okay so qa testers was
my first market in the netherlands
um
there was a bit of a bad egg that that
that was hired at the same time as me
that was sharing the desk and really
sort of negged me out
um he obviously didn't last very very
long in the business thankfully because
i think if he carried on like sitting
next to me
i would have i would have probably gone
yeah as well um
i did my first deal
so i joined i joined in the august i did
my first deal in september okay so
didn't turn that long it didn't take
long i was out in
amsterdam on client visits with my md
and another colleague of mine
she started on the monday and then quit
on the thursday oh wow
so i've gone from
feeling the feeling feeling great to how
talking about
what did you do that day to do with that
i think for me because i was so new into
the business
luckily enough i was away from my md at
the time
he
essentially said right you need you need
to call her call the manager and ask
them these questions and find out the
reason why and he sort of uh coached me
yeah when we were in the car driving to
eindhoven oh wow i think it was
um we managed to get to the bottom of it
it turns out it was just a there was
i think it was clash of personalities
between the the manager and the and the
contractor
um and we unfortunately couldn't save
that that deal yeah but that gave me
a bit more fire in the belly right to go
out there and and do more
um
and then a few weeks later
had the opportunity i almost put 11
people in
to a project
in one go so i would have gone from zero
to 11 out
like that yeah
the day before they were due to start
project
cancelled right talk to me about how do
you deal like i want to know
because this is what people really
struggle with and part of the reason why
people leave recruitment right because
they do all that hard work
they get to that point
and then
often times and sometimes
they then have to deal with that and it
can be out of their control
it's bloody hard for people and
something that people like you know what
i don't want to do this anymore how
how do you dust yourself off
that maybe like how did you do it back
then and maybe how do you do it now that
helps you get back on to just taking
action and getting back into it it's
it's testing right it is testing because
when that happens as you said the amount
of effort and work
and conversations that go into getting
to that point
it's it's it's relentless and
for me it's always
breaking down the reasons why it's
happened okay
and having a look at how you can
potentially avoid that again in the
future by implementing something into
the process
that's it
i think
it you can never in in contracts you
know projects will cancel it is going to
happen right
the best you can do is try and
keep yourself aware
of what's happening at that time but for
me
you always need to to create a new plan
if you ever find yourself in a situation
like that you need to take yourself take
yourself out of the out of the office i
go for walks all the time really yeah
people will see me i'll just get out i'm
doing these walks i just put my
headphones in go for a walk around the
block and just try and analyze
that scenario okay instead of making a
rash decision yeah i always try and go
right instead of just reacting straight
away
think about it and analyze
what can i do how can i do it have a
look at different options
and then move forward with a good plan
okay so p for people listening then i
think what you're really talking about
which i love is really
uh encouraging like if if you do have
those bad things happen
try and take a step back try and take
them as a bit of a learning opportunity
but i think the key part that i took
from there is to like like you said
dissect it understand what happened
and understand maybe parts that you
could have done better maybe could have
avoided
learn from but then also as part of that
you'll there'll be parts where you're
like you know what i can i've influenced
that i've controlled that so there's no
point me just getting worked up around
those things that i can't control right
so i really like that okay so
when did you actually do when did when
did that first proper deal go in then
and then it didn't fall through
christmas eve
christmas is received
six o'clock in the evening really yeah
so we finished it to you from august
from august had had things that you
didn't didn't quite get the ball in the
net
um and then it was christmas eve and it
was christmas eve was it just one one
contract
was a project yeah it was one contractor
out um he's still running for me wow now
like we get along very well like every
time i go out um to the netherlands
we go out for a beer um you know it's
it's it's really cool but
um but yeah i remember
we we broke up for for christmas we had
like four or five days off
and i had this opportunity that came in
like in the last few hours and i was
like right let's go i'm just going to
carry on i always
went back to cheltenham obviously for
christmas and i'm sat at my parents
house in the in the kitchen on the
laptop
working my mum's going what are you
doing what are you doing i'm like can
you leave me alone
like i'm busy yeah and the offer came
through um
[Music]
went through closed the candidate he was
absolutely buzzing something that he'd
wanted to do for
for years yeah um
and yeah safe to say that was a very
enjoyable christmas
talk to me about talk to me about then
again thinking about that mindset of
like learning growth mindset
in that period obviously not the things
that you can't control like
the the customer saying we're not going
to budget for these things you can't
control but what do you think of some of
the things that you did maybe
differently
that you feel that did why that deal
actually happened or was it it actually
went through not the things that you
couldn't control but the things that you
can control you think i think i think
for me it's it's it's having the
relationships there right with with the
candidates um
i only work with a real select handful
of people and i like to really get to
know them
not on just a career level or what they
do but on a personal level as well right
because i think
when it comes to matching them up with
teams
hiring managers
if you can match not only the skill set
but a personality and
you know
a good fit into that team
then there's no doubt that
when you get to final stages of closing
a deal
that both parties are super interested
and happy to work with each other hey
everyone a real quick one from me this
podcast would not be possible without
our amazing podcast partners vincerie
and sauce breaker because you listen to
this podcast you were able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're
all a growing recruitment business you
have to check out vincerie who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with
sourcebreaker if you want to make sure
that all of your recruiters have the
best tools on the market to stand out
and beat their competition then you have
to check out sourcebreaker use the link
in the show notes in the comments below
and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products so it seems like
fair to say then what you may became a
bit less transactional and doubled down
on the candidate relationships and those
things which
gave you or yeah gave you more of a
chance of like why that deal happened or
why future deals would happen yeah so
obviously you know coming into
recruitment everybody was like well
recruiters got bad names right and i was
like well why have they got a bad name
understood the reasons why i've set
myself out there to be
different to the stigma
of recruiters out there
as you say right moving away from just
transactional
relationships to actually having a
partnership with a client i think that's
i think that's very important
so talk to me then so did did your first
deal
good christmas great christmas
yeah so let's go into the next year then
because i think we were talking before
we started at one i think the next sort
of key moment if i'm wrong was then you
sort of identifying or picking up on
this sector that you now really love
working in
talk to you about how that happened and
why you then
sat down with tom and presented to tom
why you think this is a really good
opportunity for you and why you want to
really attack it talk to us a bit about
that so i think i think for me the the
company had a big focus around iot um
but the company was built on video
technology which is internet of things
isn't it
yeah
again probably asked me a question on
that i haven't got a clue right okay so
yeah so the business you work for is
known for that but you said they didn't
do as much in yeah
tom built the business on on video tech
he he was a video tech recruiter okay um
you know that's that that's
that's how he came about
um
for me we had a lot of potential and a
lot of good understanding in that market
and we weren't really
utilizing it to its full full potential
so sat down with tom why did you think
that though because i'm sure everyone no
everyone could maybe see that but no one
said anything
i think for me that
everybody was attacking iot we were
going you know going hammer and tongs at
iot
and you know we had we had a few house
accounts there that were that were video
based that were checking out quite a lot
of roles which is where i did my did my
first placement yeah
and then i took the time to sort of go
out and understand the market and once i
realized how big that market was
and the potential there
i said to tom i said look we we're
sitting on something big
there's
ample opportunity out there as well to
grow
to grow into to a phenomenal size right
um
and he listened to me he looked at it
and that's where he gave me the green
light to
to go ahead and start focusing purely on
and i was like nine months into your
journey right nine months since my
journey so talk to me about
just
getting a bit granular here what were
some of the things that you that got you
excited about the nation sector was it
the amount of live vacancies was it you
know what from the companies i've spoken
to they told me how big it could be in
the next two three five years what got
you really excited what sort of
indicators did you find i think for me
that it was it was something that
everybody uses
daily right
everybody has a streaming subscription
of some kind everybody not all of them
if not all of them right
i'm an absolute nightmare for it i think
i have about seven right yeah i said the
average person before he has quite a few
definitely more than one i'd say that's
it
so so for me to be able to go right you
know
sit there at the pub with my mates and
go i'm working with this company you
know i've brought this app
over from america
into the uk and european market
for me that was that was what was
exciting um
i love movies as well right so for me
it's something that i'm always using i
have an understanding of what they're
looking to achieve in their yeah when
they when they launch a product to
market right so
for me i just found it really
interesting um and
it sounds like it was just just a bit of
common sense really that this is always
gonna be needed if not even it's going
to become more and more popular more and
more companies going to want to have
some sort of opportunity to give
something to their customers in the
video digital way
okay so
let's let's start talking about from
that moment then talk to him about what
was obviously you said that um you had
some stuff going on but maybe it was
being left alone or you weren't the team
weren't focusing on as much because
they're on the iot staff what was the
plan and what did you say to tom right
this is what i'm going to do what was
the approach so
i mapped out my market again i was only
working in the netherlands
at this point um i think as well i did
one of
i think i did a perm deal actually uh
the the rare perm deal i think i've done
five
in three years but this was a rare perm
deal that i did with a client in the uk
so i started to map out
the market what it looked like in each
individual country in europe that we
were involved with
what it looked like further afield um
and tried to have a look at sort of what
emerging tech
was
going to be prominent over the next two
to three years
and essentially built out a full
bd business development list
based around that so talk to me about
that just quickly because you hear that
a lot don't you and i'm sure you've
helped guys and girls now with this
what does that exercise actually look
like is it i'm going through linkedin
i'm find one company i then might find
their competitors
like just talk to me a bit about what
that process actually looked like it may
sound really simple and basic here but i
think that it's good because you hear
that technology a lot don't you market
mapping but how did you actually do that
i think it's so important for people to
do people take it for granted a lot of
people will do it at the start and then
they won't do it
yeah i try to always keep
in tune with what's happening in the
market so for me it's all about
forums
conferences webinars
um newsletters
um there are a lot of clients out there
that will write a personal newsletter on
their own view on what's happening in
the market i sign up to those and i just
try to absorb
all the information possible
um write down sort of key notes about
what's the sort of common topics uh
though and the purpose of that isn't
isn't because jamie wants to become a
video digital
expert in the sense as in like you can
then do a job in that industry it's
about all about understanding what's
going on in the industry that i'm trying
to help support and grow right yeah
that's sometimes where people can get
lost i feel like it's like
the people may view that as like they're
trying to they're trying to get all this
information in so they can be
as competent as the people that they
place but you're never going to be as
competent as those people are you and
you don't get paid to do that so why
you're doing that
is because you can then have a better
grasp of like where things are going the
inside right that's it i mean when you
talk about competence i could barely use
a laptop
when i started at recruitment and tom
and sam will tell you the amount of
times that i was just calling them up
and saying my laptop's broken i need a
new one
so i would never be a software developer
right but for me it was being able to
understand
the process that they go through when
developing a product and being able to
talk about that
with candidates and with clients
as well to show that you know yes i'm a
i'm a recruiter
but i understand
what you're what i'm always consistently
learning i'm trying to engross myself in
the market industry that's it
okay so let's let's just reverse
engineer them from like where you are
today then and then we can get into this
um so
until so where in terms of weekly gp
wise where are you at today uh just over
20 yeah
at the moment so as we were saying i
think it's something that we're saying
before we started right had someone
um sit down with me marriage from sr2
who got to around 15-16 that was a great
milestone and then like externally i
think sort of 15 20 whatever i didn't
work in contract recruitment but it's
considered a quite hefty and like really
successful milestone so let's unpack
this because there'll be people
listening to this that want to get to
that have huge ambitions to get there
so i guess the first thing to sort of
ask really is like what were some of the
sort of key
building blocks or key milestones that
you think
really enabled you to
get towards that point and get to that
point today do you think
let's sort of start there so i think i
think the first lockdown i think covid
was probably the first key milestone
right we're at a point where
the world stopped
everybody's shutting their homes 23
hours a day um
all i did was just double down
on work i sat at my desk from seven
o'clock in the morning until 10 11
o'clock at night
just doing new business calls
constantly
constantly and it sounds ridiculous
but that was probably
one of the the first steps to to get
into where i am now is i just spent time
not necessarily you know calling up and
trying to win projects or trying to get
a role but just checking in
understanding people you know
building relationships with with with
managers building relationships with
with candidates
clients
and
understanding and mapping out my market
through through that and i think that
was probably the key point
i think when the world started to open
up again
and projects started to go live
i started to get inundated with people
were calling up going you know i i
remember you're
you're an expert in in video tech i'm
looking for this or i'm looking to build
a team of x amount of developers for
this project can you help me
and that was like a real turning point
of going wow okay like
everything that was banged on to me to
do during the first nine months
is now starting to
you're starting to see the fruits of
your labor right through that i love
that and then i think one of the other
things that you shared with me right was
then
obviously you
typically you'd always done that
amsterdam market but then you
obviously then internationalized as well
right yeah so i probably got like sort
of three or four key clients per
geographical location yeah um and i
branched out and carried on branching
out so i now cover
north america
uk
emea
and aipac as well talk to you about
like
getting it right in those different
cultures or environments
how would you like is there much is
there much difference
in terms of how you approach things it
just the nuance of like
it's
what are the differences it's very
different okay from
area to area so
you know in europe mainland europe
everything's very direct you know
business first um straight to the point
which i like um
you know it's not to say that
everybody's massively different but it's
just that it's just the way that you
approach business is just different with
with each with each country
um
for me
again something that i enjoy is actually
finding out you know building that
relationship with people and
understanding their their views and
their culture and
and adapting to that i think that's like
a big big part of the reason why i
branched out to to the size that i did
what the other obviously i think i've
seen to you right a lot of people are on
this journey of going to america what
have been some of the key differences
you picked up there do you think that
you have to get right or
it's
everybody's everybody's looking to go to
america now right you know i
we started to look at it two years ago
um for me it's it's
you don't want to go there just because
everybody else is going there you want
to go there because it's the right thing
and you want to implement the right
level of service
to clients as well
so for us so for me in particular i
focused more on u.s businesses that were
looking to come over to the uk in europe
and be in that
bridge for them so that they can
understand the market
and i can tell them
or introduce them to
developers that they wouldn't
necessarily be able to attract
in the in the first place i think that
was the probably the key difference
so talk obviously i think something
that's been quite fundamental in
you getting up to this point is
like getting some like really big
accounts right then what you call it
msas or whatever um obviously not
looking for names here i don't i don't
need to know what clients but i guess
like
looking at that and how you've achieved
some of those things obviously people
will be interested to know
these accounts and customers and logos
can oftentimes be some of the most
difficult to get in with
but looking back
in hindsight when you got some of these
doors opened like
why do you think he was able to do that
persistence really yeah persistence um
but i'm sure there's so many other
recruiters being persistent so
i think i think you've always got to be
able to add value at every
uh every point or every touch point that
you have with a client okay my best my
best account and one of my favorite
accounts to work with took 19 weeks from
negotiations
it's 19 weeks 19 weeks
i started it in
[Music]
started it in the february
and had it all signed off in the in the
september wow
how do you stay focused and engaged in
that long ago i tell you what right i
literally
physically pulled my arrow
right over it it was it was it was crazy
because
you know it was it was a really good
like initial engagement everything was
going really well everything that we had
they wanted
um
uh so we started we started interviewing
people um started presenting people to
them
and then for
for them they were they were coming over
to the uk and europe right so they're
exploring all of their different legal
routes and so there was no clear
direction
into how we were going to get an
agreement in place right
so that took a little little bit of time
once we had that in place it was then
right
all of the legislations
for recruiting
remote people in the uk and europe to
work alongside their regulations in in
in the us
um and as we got further and further
into the negotiations it turned out our
candidate paul would get shorter and
shorter due to different agreements and
it's like right you know
for for us it's having it's having the
valuable com
adding adding value to each to each
conversation so
every week we would have a meeting with
an update meeting well there's 19 weeks
over those 19 weeks
uh a meeting about you know if there was
a big change like right let's let's get
together let's discuss it so everybody
can understand because
everybody was learning at the same time
so we did that we did that together as a
as a as a like pure partnership
basically so i guess what i'd take from
that then there would have been a lot of
recruiters that maybe wouldn't
wouldn't have been willing to commit for
19 weeks yeah would it have been to like
some people get bored like well just
don't bother calling back
right i've seen it so many times it
doesn't happen too difficult don't want
to deal with it
i'm going to brush it under the carpet
so there's one thing getting these like
big house big logos talk to me about
what what have you what's jamie then
done to like really maximize
the opportunity then
which is then maybe led to like you then
getting bigger logos other companies
like because i think there's one thing
working hard then like the
quite quite the real work starts right
where you're then having to deliver on
the agreements to help the support
what do you think you've done well
and how have you sort of made sure you
then maximize your opportunity because i
know it's then led on to bigger things
yeah i think you know again it all comes
down to relationships right
don't just look at a placement as a
placement you know
look to really support that client in in
that area and and and build the
relationship with them for to the point
where they're going to refer you to to
other managers right so one of my other
big accounts started off as a as a small
company in in canada
they were acquired by a big business
and then those managers at that that
company
sent my name out to the to the business
and before you knew it i had a global
agreement with one of the largest
largest uh streaming businesses in in
the globe right
um i think that's important is
showing the the level that you would go
to to support that that hiring manager
and deliver on what you actually say
if you do that and you do it well
then you know
yeah they're they're just going to
support you
where do people because i think what
you're talking about there is like
as a recruiter who's in the thick of it
can maybe miss like um not see that that
could happen if you get what i mean yeah
it's like where do you know i mean like
clearly what you had yourself up to
really good standard you're really
committed to delivering great service
all these things
and then because you showed up every
single day and delivered on that that
meant when an opportunity like that
happened which you can plan for they
said look jamie he's living outstanding
experience this is why i need to speak
to them yeah where where do you think
recruiters
go wrong and like because i think it's
something to be short-sighted right
i don't know i just i it should be
interesting to get your thoughts i'm
sure you can see this as other people
you have to remind them day in day out
no if you keep doing this
good things will happen yeah it's simple
isn't it you don't ask don't ask you
don't get
i always ask is there anybody else that
you can refer me to in the business you
know i've done i've delivered on xyz for
you is there anybody else that's looking
to implement something similar in the
business i'm more than happy to have a
chat with them let's just have a chat to
see if i can help
and and that's where the referrals come
from
so
let's go into some granular stuff
because i'm interested in thoughts on
this before we finish so
i want to definitely ask you around like
your day plan done if you're an
organized person but people always know
this obviously you've got um a high week
tgp so i'm assuming there's a lot a lot
of stuff going on
but when we spoke before um in
preparation for today something that you
said really
stopped me you were saying around like
how sometimes you feel like recruiters
can get lost in like
or just get confused with all the
different ways now that you could do
recruitment if that's
doing bd sourcing candidate these things
right i know that clearly you're someone
that's willing to write different things
you've got a podcast that you do that
i've seen you obviously building your
brand a lot but i wanted to ask you like
you were very dead set on like for me
what really
moved the needle was every single day i
wanted to focus on doing the basics
extremely well and that's what i really
focused on
so talks about that how can people
master the basics and in your
perspective what are the the basics for
a successful contract recruiter that you
keep top of mind
yeah so
like you said right it's with everybody
trying to be different to everyone else
out in the market there's there's so
much noise out there and it is so easy
to get lost in the noise and
if you're trying to focus on 20
different things that can improve you as
a as a recruiter or as a person
you're not really going to put you know
100 effort into all of those 20 things
for me
i i went back to
write what was i doing in in lockdown
right how did i build my desk to to to
where it was so the basics for me are
always just picking up the phone and
building a relationship over over the
phone right
we're in a mad digital world at the
moment where
it's so much easier to send a text an
email or a linkedin message to to get
something going
i for i myself i'd i've got rid of like
socials because i just can't i can't
deal with the noise and
clients and and and
candidates won't really look at linkedin
anymore because they're getting hounded
by by by recruiters on there okay so
picking up the phone and just building
relationships is like a basic skill set
that i think that you need
that's that's important
organize
organization granted hands up tom would
probably laugh at me i was not organized
at all for about two years really yeah i
was a mess um i would essentially just
come in
i have i don't know right so it's it's
kind of chaotic but i quite like being
chaotic a little bit right
um but for me i always had like a main
focus but i would never really plan a
day properly
i've really started to do that in the
last year which is where i think again
i made i made the stepping stone to get
to my weekly gp so
i would i will plan my day
not to the t but i will i would set six
important tasks that i need to achieve
the next day
in order to get me yeah yeah before i go
home six important tasks i need i need
to execute the next day in order for me
to achieve my goal by the end of the
week okay
so organisation
being on the phone and
basics
just following through just deliver on
what you promise
to clients and candidates
nobody likes being let down
right and if you let the client down or
the candidate down ultimately you're
going to let yourself down
and that's where you're going to find
yourself in a funk
right
if you if you've tried absolutely
everything that you can to deliver on
something that you've said that you're
going to deliver to
then you've done you then you can you
can finish work knowing that you've
given that you've given everything
i think for me is like those those three
areas are so basic and people like glaze
over them so much i think it's with
those things that you said that mixed
with like holding yourself to a really
good standard relentless commitment
so talk to me about before we finish
then um
talk to me about just give me some more
details on what that day plan might look
like then because this is what people
love next you said
before jamie leaves
he's going to think of um he's going to
understand what the six important tasks
are for the next day that he has to the
non-negotiable that he has to do weren't
in the office until they're done
what does that day then look like are
you chunking your day into things that
you need to get done like what does your
actual day look like yeah so
i run my day in sprints okay four in
four 90 minute sprints um i don't do any
admin at all in those sprints i'll break
that down into either
a business development sprint so i'm
gonna you know i won't even put how many
dials i'm gonna do i'm just gonna go
right i wanna have three or four
conversations
with hiring managers
with a goal of what i want to get out of
those conversations right whether that's
a follow-up book call
a new bit of information about the
market
a new role etc there's probably three or
four three or four points i look at
there
the second would be
making sure that my team
are set ready to go spending time with
them coaching them
you know
i'm working with some really great guys
at the moment and
i want them to be as successful as i am
so the more that i can feed down to them
the quicker that they're going to get to
that success as well because it's fresh
i've done it in the last two and a half
three years when you're doing those
sprints do you say like
don't bother me or like obviously i'm
here if you need me but i'm gonna be
focusing on this so yeah so i give them
access to my diary so they can literally
book in a time to to speak to me yeah
they'll see in my diary you know
the reasons why i'm blocked out and what
i'm doing in that time so they will just
they will just leave me alone
and i'd get them to come to me with a
solution not a problem okay because a
lot of people will come to you with a
problem
and they haven't thought so how do you
get people to do that you say next time
i say to them i was like right if you've
got a problem or something you're
struggling with
think about it come to me with how you
think yeah you're going to tackle that
i'll listen to that and then i'll help
and then i'll help rather than jamie
i've got a problem with this or i've got
a challenge with this yeah can you can
you help me
yeah why are you getting them to do that
because
they learn
that way
i learned that way and tom did it with
me
i was a nightmare of going tom i've got
this problem he's like have you got a
solution yeah no i haven't got a
solution he's like right come to me when
you've got a solution
for them it gets them thinking of what
they potentially have to do in that
scenario
and then when i spend the time with them
on that on that point
they'll then learn how to deal with that
scenario so when it comes up again
they'll know what to do next time i love
that so as we come to the end here then
what what's jamie keeping top of mind
now like you've
clearly it wasn't it's a bumpy road
you put in a shitload of work commitment
blood sweat and tears
you now obviously obviously got to a
point where
you're successful you're achieving good
numbers must feel great considering like
where you was however many years ago
what are you keeping top of mind now so
you don't become complacent or i don't
know what do you keep on top of mine to
try and maintain this performance whilst
also obviously trying to enjoy the
journey right yeah well what's top of
mind here and then let's sort of end on
this what do you keep top of mind to
keep you at the top of your game and
maintain that performance so
i've got i've got some pretty big
personal goals
that i want to achieve right
for one i'd never even thought i'd be
earning the money that that i'd be
earning today ever in my life right um
we've got a real passion for for
property um so an investment property i
want to invest in property like whether
that's
buying a house flipping doing it up and
flipping it um looking at buying
building a letting portfolio yeah you
know but that takes money right so i
have a financial goal that i have to
here that can enable you to do that and
you know if i don't do the deals and i
don't maintain where i'm at at the
moment
that goal is only going to be further
away and i'm going to get to that as
quick as as quick as possible so that's
probably my main driver
behind
why i do what i do
and then anything else any advice for
other people listen to this there's a
final thing that
could be useful with
like i don't know they get to a point
where like for example i think maybe
sort of where you got to know you've
been thinking about getting to this
point it'd be great when i get there
now you hear us like right what's the
next thing i need to keep motivated so
clearly you've done the work on like
right this is my goal and where i want
to get to personally but any other
advice for people listen to this that i
don't know it can be quite difficult
when you get to like a really high point
and then remain motivated right anything
else that could be helpful for people
yeah i think just focus on just
securing the next deal
if you focus on securing the next deal
then the numbers will add up quickly we
were talking before right
sam walked up to me in the office in
january and goes do you know you're
running over 20k a week
and i said
no and he was like do you know do you
know what that's you know do you know
how big that number is yeah you weren't
thinking about that i didn't have a clue
yeah i was just thinking about getting
the next candidate in
securing the next project yeah um that
was what was important to me i just the
figures
i i i cast aside
jeremy thanks coming on the pod i
appreciate it
thank you so much for listening to the
episode i hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode